this patch of land 20 kilometers outside
the capital Brasilia used to be the
biggest landfill site in Latin America
last year the dump was closed and the 60
meter high mountain of garbage was
covered with earth construction waste is
still being dumped there although that's
illegal the national waste policy aims
to eradicate landfills and promote
recycling with residual waste either
incinerated or going to sanitary
landfills that protect the environment
but there are still two and a half
thousand open landfill sites across the
country
Lucia Fernandez worked here as a waste
picker for 20 years mainly at night she
supported her four children by selling
anything of value she found they used to
live in a shantytown right beside the
dump we were always in a struggle with
the trucks the bulldozers and with more
than a thousand other people working
here it was survival of the fittest you
took as much as you could get and for
women it was very challenging people
lost their lives working here it's very
tough
at first Lucia Fernandez was very much
against the closure of the garbage dump
she had little faith in the city
authorities pledged to provide jobs for
some 750 trash pickers in new recycling
facilities but now that's where she
works and she's changed her mind
no capping say he do [ __ ] I never
thought I might one day have a real job
me a simple waste picker with no rights
and no social insurance and now I work
here I even have an office
if only it paid a little better it would
be perfect she used to earn four times
as much scavenging on the old dump she
and her colleagues now belonged to a
cooperative that operates one of the
recycling facilities what they earn
depends on how much trash they sought on
average only about 200 euros a month so
far because for now not enough waste is
delivered to the facility Lucia
Fernandez is a supervisor she makes sure
the work is done properly there aren't
enough people working on the conveyor
belt a lot of recyclable material gets
through then we have to check it to make
sure things don't end up in residual
waste that don't belong there if I see
that happening I put more people on at
the end of the belt the process is set
to become more efficient with the help
of some students from the university of
Brasilia until recently their professor
Powell or Celso dos Reis Gomes was
deputy director of the municipal
sanitation Authority he helped
restructure brasilia's waste management
systems
everybody is collecting something
different she's sorting out glass
bottles she's sorting out plastic
bottles further along somebody is
pulling out the cardboard it's possible
the process could be made more efficient
if the positions were switched around
that's something we need to test but not
all the trash delivered here to be
sorted can be recycled much of it has to
be disposed of the aim of the program is
to increase the proportion of waste that
can be recycled everything that can be
sorted and sold is returned to the
production chain to the recycling
industry it doesn't end up being dumped
so we're saving the cost of taking it to
the landfill extending the lifespan of
that site and reducing emissions
this is Brazilians new landfill site far
more waste is ending up here than
planned one mountain of garbage is
complete and being covered with earth
the pit for the second one has been
lined with waterproof sheeting to
protect the groundwater from
contamination the plan is to capture the
gas produced by the decomposing waste
and use it in Brazil greenhouse gas
emissions from the waste sector have
continued to rise dramatically in recent
years the German Development Agency GI Z
is advising brasilia's sanitation
authority on how to reduce emissions
a judge they envisioned we're investing
in expanding waste sorting and the
composting of organic waste that will
allow us to reduce the volume of
residual waste and thereby emissions of
methane as well soul-g gas yo mismo
tiempo brought at the same time we aim
to raise public awareness so people sort
their recyclable trash
professor Paulo dos Reis has organized a
cross-disciplinary seminar at the
university 90 students from various
fields are working on developing
sustainable waste management solutions
one approach is to make waste sorting
more efficient another is to focus on
technology trucks sensors logistics
others aim to raise environmental
awareness how can the public be involved
more closely in the waste recycling
process the program brings students
together with representatives of the
municipal sanitation Authority the
recycling cooperatives and also
commercial enterprises in cooperation
with GI Z the university of Brasilia is
setting up a postgraduate program in
waste management among Brazil cities the
capital has taken the lead in developing
a sustainable waste management strategy
waste sorting and collection have just
been expanded across the city
Lucia Fernandez is optimistic about her
future they'll now be more waste
delivered to her cooperative to sort and
that means she and her colleagues will
soon be earning more
you
you